this is vitalife
who is sitting somewhere here yeah
and uh just to put this into context um
let me start with a two-minute version
of this talk okay so
at the high level uh this talk is about
uh
active about learning algorithms that
are active and try to minimize the need
for expert intervention okay so as you
might know the classic supervised
learning approach depends on the
assumption that humans can annotate or
label all the data available for
training
however uh most modern machine learning
applications have massive amounts of raw
or unlabeled or anarchy data okay and
this is why
there has been tremendous effort and
interest in recent years in machine
learning to design learning algorithms
in particular active learning algorithms
that most effectively utilize all the
available data while minimizing again
the need for expert intervention
and this has been a major area of
research
in machine learning and learning theory
um
with many exciting results concerning
the label complexity uh the sample
complexity of active learning okay
however uh very much less is known and
very few positive algorithmic results
for normal time algorithms have been
proposed that can tolerate noise
and uh in historical original goals to
address this problem and in particular
what we do in this work we design
we propose a framework for designing a
certain type of learning algorithms
called statistical active learning
algorithms
but
oops oh no
i'm sure i can talk very fast
that's not the problem
right so
right so in this work we designed a
framework we present a framework for
designing a certain type of algorithms
namely statistical active learning
algorithms that enjoy two main
properties so first of all um
in this framework we can transform any
polynomial time statistical active
learning algorithm that is probably
effective uh in noise free scenarios
into polynomial time
active learning algorithm that is
probably effective when the data is
corrupted by random classification noise
okay and we also for commonly used
concept spaces like thresholds and
linear separators we also present
statistical uh active learning
algorithms so these two facts together
it is the first known uh algorithms
active learning algorithms that are
label efficient polynomial time and can
tolerate random classification noise
okay
and second uh and this is very relevant
for this workshop we show that the
algorithms that we design this framework
very naturally satisfy differential
privacy okay and this could be highly
relevant for
uh scenarios uh like financial record
analysis or medical record analysis
where the data is both expensive to
label and sensitive
okay
so this is a two minutes version of my
talk now in terms of the structure of my
talk i will first start by
briefly reminding you the typical way to
analyze learning algorithms in the past
supervised learning setting then i'll
present the statistical query learning
framework for passive learning
then i'll introduce active learning the
way it's normally described
and then i'll present our model and
describe the results in this model
okay
so
in the classic supervised learning uh
setting which is captured by the classic
models of uh the pac model rebellion and
the statistical and theory frame
acrobatic so in this mode as a learning
algorithm uses labeled examples for
instance email messages labeled spam or
not if you want to do some detection
okay and formally in this frameworks we
assume that there is some underlying
probability distribution over the space
of unlabeled examples
and
for instance about the space
of email messages
and in the training phase
first the learning galaxy gets to see a
random sample of these examples
these examples are then labeled by an
expert and these labeled examples are
then input to a learning algorithm
which then outputs a classifier right
and the goal of the algorithm is to
output a classifier but that's all in
random examples that come from the same
underlying distribution okay so formally
in the settings the london gets to see a
set of labeled examples
which are assumed to be drawn iid from
some fixed but non-distribution over the
instant space and they are labeled
according to some fixed but unknown
target function c star
okay and for my talk i'm actually going
to know by
uh p
the
uh the the distribution uh uh induced by
uh d and the data functions start
right and in the path model we also
assume that the target function itself
comes from a known concept class like
linear separators but it can be anything
else decision lists decision trees and
so on
okay and when the goal of the algorithm
is to do some optimization over the
given sample in order to find the
hypotheses that has a small error rate
with respect to the original
distribution
and uh for my talk uh
by error rate i really mean the z the
classic zero and error loss of
classification error loss
uh
basically probably most of the others
that we have seen like adaboost and svm
have been designed for this scenario
okay
now
uh
so this is the classic way to analyze uh
passive supervised learning algorithms
now motivated by the idea of trying to
uh to have a unified way to design
learning algorithms that are tolerant to
random classification noise
uh michael cohen's introducing 93 a
framework uh called the statistical
query framework for passive supervised
learning
okay and uh so this is a framework for
designing learning algorithms
that only operate by statistical
properties of the data rather via
individual examples
okay and in particular the way to think
about these types of algorithms
is that they interact with a statistical
query oracle but in the following way so
what the housing can do he can ask
please tell me what is the probability
that the random examples has some
property phi
and please tell me that up to edit
additive or tau
okay so basically the sq algorithm
interacts with the sqrt by a number of
such queries and based on such queries
he updates his own hypotheses and then
at the end the goal of the algorithm is
to output the
of through error rate at most epsilon
okay just uh
as a quick example
assume that uh we are trying to learn a
threshold function on the real line uh
actually even let's just met a tanker
intentional function the interval 0 1
and
just for instance in the special case
when the underlying distribution is
uniform we know that it's uniform
then
what we can do is just simply ask the
sql called the query please tell me what
is the probability that a random example
is positive and please tell me that up
to tolerance epsilon
okay and once you get this back it's
very easy to see that we can output one
minus p and the hypothesis that will
output would have to error rate at most
epsilon
okay now when the underlying
distribution is not uh uniform so in
general after we get the answer to the
first query what we have to do is then
ask a number of statistical a number of
unlabeled statistical queries and to
find the point z such as the probability
but the random example belongs to the
interval zero one is very close to p and
then we can again now put z and it's
very easy to see that actually uh this
will have through error rate and most
epsilon
okay
so this is just an example
now in general
these statistical query algorithms enjoy
a number of interesting properties
okay and the first one is
that we can simulate statistical query
algorithms from random examples and this
is simply just
because
uh we can estimate the result of a query
phi at the tolerance tau
just from the empirical expect with very
high probability from the empirical
aspect by using the empirical
expectation over
juan vertov square logan over delta
random examples
okay so basically if we are able to
design a learning algorithm that uses
only a polynomial number of statistical
queries such as the tolerance tau is not
too small then we immediately also get a
polynomial time algorithm for the usual
park statistical learning theory
framework where the algorithm has access
to random examples
okay
now to be totally honest i don't
particularly uh think about learning
algorithms in the sq model so they might
look a little bit
non-intuitive at first but the nice fact
is they
enjoy uh
two main properties and in particular
the first one is uh that
um
they can be easily made robust to random
classification noise so in particular
that uh we can basically so if we have a
polynomial time algorithm that is
statistical
and is computationally efficient in
noise-cast scenarios we can immediately
transform it into a polynomial time
algorithm that is
tolerant to random classification noise
where the label of each example is
flipped independently with a fixed
constant probability
so they have strong noise tolerance
properties it's a genetic reduction okay
so that's a nice thing
and in fact many
non-machine learning algorithms like
perceptron and so on
do have statistical query analogs having
presented the first one in 96
and
in fact most everything almost
everything that we know to learn
efficiently can be learned by
statistical queries
by statistical query algorithms
so they are pretty general
okay and from the point of view of this
workshop uh the the very nice thing is
that uh algorithm design in this
framework can be very naturally turned
into organs that satisfy differential
privacy
which can be relevant for many scenarios
and this is
this fact is from a
2000 paper by
blam dwork
actually and see
right so the statistical queries
algorithms have a number of very nice
properties
now
this is all about passive supervised
learning and
uh
which which i mentioned earlier it's a
technique it's an approach learning
approach
that operates under the assumption that
humans can annotate all the data
available for training right which is
clearly highly unrealistic for many of
the today's settings
and as mentioned the technique that has
been developed or an approach that has
been anal
considered for circumventing this is
active learning which is what i'm going
to talk about next
now so what is active learning
if you think
i didn't expect it but it looks like i
also have an active learning expert in
the audience
so
right so what is active learning so
actually the easiest way to describe
active learning is uh his lay one from
uh
yeah
so right there
good so the easiest way to describe
active learning is in the normal
learning scenario where you have access
to random examples okay so in the active
learning scenario uh we
the learning housing first gets to see a
large set of unlabeled examples
and then it can indirectly ask for
labels of unlabeled examples of its own
choice from the pool okay and the goal
is to use this interaction
in order to drastically reduce the
labeling effort
okay so basically in this scenario we
assume that the learning algorithm uh
has access to large amounts of unable
data
and uh here
and also it can interactively ask for
labels of examples of its own choice and
so the goal of the learner is to be
smart to be adaptive in order to learn
with much your label
examples so really darwin wants to pick
examples that are somehow informative in
order to be labeled
okay and let me just mention that from a
theoretical point of view the canonical
example showing that uh
active learning can be
uh actually significantly better and
passive learning is again that of
learning a threshold function
uh in this case it turns out active
learning provides an exponential
improvement um in labor complexity over
the classic passive learning
and the argument is really simple so i'm
just going to quickly go through it so
let's just assume noise three scenarios
then what we can do we first can just
draw one of our epsilon unlabeled
samples
now if we knew the correct labels of
those soluble samples
just from standard sample complexity
results from passive learning we could
just output the consistent classifiers
to those labeled examples and we would
know that a very high probability we are
doing well
now the key point is that in active
learning we can just do minor research
and we've only log one of our epsilon
requests we can infer the true labels of
those one over epsilon label samples and
then we can now put a classifier that is
consistent with those
which should have probability very
accurate
okay so basically inactive learning one
any logon of epsilon label requests to
learn an abstract accurate classifier
now passive learning probably requires
omega 1
omega 1 over epsilon labor requests so
you get an exponential improvement in
this simple case
okay now this is just a simple example
now
uh the question of when active learning
provides an exponential improvement over
or when active learning actually
provides significant benefits or passive
learning has been studied in the recent
years in much much more general
scenarios
and there has been a lot of exciting
activity uh in this area
now
uh for the purpose of this talk i'm
gonna roughly classify the results into
two categories
um just to put my work into context
so
on one extreme at one extreme we have
very very general active learning
algorithms called disagreement based
active learning algorithms
which at a high level operate
by keeping a set of surviving
classifiers
so by going around in each round they
have a set of surviving classifiers and
in that round we only query points
if they found in the region of
disagreement of the currency to
surviving classifiers so even in the
region of agreement we don't have to
query for the label so only query for
labels of points that fall in the
original disagreement okay and we use
those labels to then throw out
classifiers from consideration
if we are statistically confident that
they are suboptimal
okay so this is how these algorithms
operate at a high level actually the
first algorithm of this type was
analyzed in one of my old papers
and then it has been reanalyzed and in
in even more general scenarios and
variants of these algorithms have been
proposed by many researchers so this is
a long line of work and including leon
here he has analyzed the this type of
algorithms
now
these algorithms have a very nice
property but they are very general
they work for harvest basically for any
type of noise and even other serial
label noise okay so this is the their
main benefit
however the main problem is that they
are computationally inefficient okay so
uh that's my problem now this is one
extreme and this is really where most of
the work in active learning has been
spent in the past 10 years now the other
extreme we also have very specific
results that are computationally
efficient but for very specific concept
spaces like linear separators and really
only when the in the noise three
scenarios
okay so for instance many uh researchers
have shown
uh
in various ways that for instance if
you're trying to learn a linear
separator in rd so in high dimensions
then if the underlying distribution is
uniform over the surface of the
hemisphere you're going to get an
exponential improvement in sample
complexity
okay
so really the two types of results that
we have currently in the literature is
at one extreme we have very very general
uh computational inefficient algorithms
that work for adversary real type of
noise at the other extreme we have a
very specific algorithms that only work
for very specific cases but only for
nature scenarios so really
epsilon the accuracy parameter so it's
like you do
the you you go from the over epsilon to
diligent over epsilon and that's
probably
uh the best you can do there is a lower
bound actually one of my papers
yeah
yeah please ask questions of course
good right so basically uh so in this
context really the main open question in
this area is to design
polynomial time algorithms that are
labeled efficient so we want to design
polynomial time active learning
algorithms that are label efficient but
also tolerate noise
okay and this is the original motivation
for our work and this is why we
introduce this active statistical query
learning framework
which is a framework as i mentioned
earlier for designing polymer time
active learning algorithms that are
tolerant to random classification noise
and as a bonus they also enjoy very
nice differential privacy guarantees
all right
so now in our framework instead of
having access to random examples our
algorithms will only get active
estimates of statistical properties of
the data in the following sense
so
now a query
will be a pair so it's a filter function
chi and also property phi okay and the
filter function chi specifies the
probability that we're going to query
the label of example x
just for simplicity you can think of chi
just being the indicator function of a
set of informative examples and of
property phi is some property of the
target function that you want to
estimate
okay and so then basically from the
algorithm our learning algorithm can get
from the active sq oracle and estimate
of the probability that property phi is
satisfied on a random example given that
the random example also satisfies the
filter chi
and it gets this estimate up to additive
tolerance
tau if the probability that the filter
chi satisfied
is lower bonded by this uh
tilde tolerance tau f
okay and then the learning algorithm can
interact with the active sq oracle by a
number of such queries and the goal is
to again the goal is to output a
classifier of small error
okay now the key point is that when we
simulate this from random examples
the number of labeled examples only
depends inversely polynomially
in tau so it only depends on one over
tau
and the smaller filter tolerance will
actually gonna go only in the number of
unlabeled examples
so that's the key point so basically
it's easy to see that we actually can
simulate such a query by using so many
level examples so many labeled examples
right and the the the interesting fact
is that now
if we can design an active sq algorithm
where we are able to keep the tolerance
tau large
even if the filter tolerance potentially
becomes small we get significant benefit
in the number of labeled examples that
we need to learn well
can you explain filter tolerance again
so i'm going to have an example
so okay i can go back and explain it but
i also have a quick example that's fine
i think the example will make it clear
if it's not clear it's uh then i'll come
back yeah so let me know
good so let me just make a couple of
comments uh
uh actually maybe i can just jump
directly to the example and come back to
the comments later okay how about i do
that okay so just to um good so just
let's go back to the threshold example
site as i mentioned earlier in the
passive sq in order to learn well all we
have to do is to ask the query please
tell so if the underlying distribution
is uniform in the passive sql you have
to do is to ask the query please tell me
the probability of a random example is
positive and please tell me that up to
tolerance epsilon once we had that back
we had an accurate classifier absolute
classifier however in order to
to answer this query we needed one of
our epsilon square labeled examples
now the point is that when we do active
learning we can use the filter and we
can localize
and we we are able to design learning
algorithms that only use constant
tolerance
so concentrate style even if the filter
tolerance tau f becomes smaller you only
have constant tolerance tau so we need
we need we're gonna need fewer labeled
examples
okay and just to make this more concrete
let's assume that we currently know that
our threshold function belongs to the
interval a b
yeah now what we're gonna do we can ask
is that the active statistical query
which is please tell me the probability
that a random example is positive given
that it falls in the interval a b
and we're going to ask the field that
are also going to put the theoretical
tolerance here to be epsilon so we're
going to ask this question only the
interval a b is not too small
right before the filter tolerance comes
into place
right we're going to ask this question
please tell me the probability but the
random example is positive given that it
falls in the interval a b
we've been tolerance tau which is one
over four
okay now it's not uh one can just go for
a little bit of math and it's not easy
it's not difficult to see but we can use
the answer to that query within
tolerance one over four
to then basically output an interval a
prime b prime that is twice smaller than
the interval a b
is the property where the target
function belongs to that interval
okay so in this case basically the
filter tolerance itself will uh we can
can go very small it can be it can go up
a level it'll never be smaller than
epsilon because on the interval a prime
b prime is smaller than epsilon stop
but it can go as small as epsilon
however that the tolerance itself that
we use is the only constant
so basically we go for logan over
epsilon rounds in each round the
tolerance uh tau we need is one over
four
so basically we need a constant number
pretty much a constant number of labeled
examples to answer such a query
potentially more unlabeled examples
because the field tolerance can be as
small as epsilon
in the right before the last round
but the key point is that we go longer
epsilon rounds in each round only the
constant number of labeled examples so
in total we need basically logan over
epsilon labeled examples and more
unlabeled examples one over absolutely
but examples
so did i clarify
so your client is adaptive it changes
from around absolutely yeah yeah but
it's not clear from there
yeah yeah
it's normal it's adapt even even kai
even five will be
i can allow them to be adaptive
definitely
okay let me just actually go back uh and
just make one more comment just uh about
so clearly let me make these two notes
like i wanted to make two notes so
basically clearly this model generalize
the statistical query framework of
of currents uh in a passive sq is just
like an active sql chi is all i identity
one right everything is relevant and the
tilde tolerance is one okay
and uh
and let me also make another comment so
our act so
we like again the active squares that we
are looking at are please tell me what
is the probability but a random example
satisfies property phi given that it
satisfies the filter chi now clearly we
can write this as a
ratio of two expectations respect to the
original distribution
and so in principle we could just get
the answer to this
to our question by using two passive
statistical queries
however to really get this of
intolerance tau we might end up having
to estimate this numerator with
intolerance tau times this expectation
over here
that the random example satisfies
uh uh
that is expectation over here and so
this could mean that we might need too
many more labeled examples so if we
simulate it in the usual sq model we
just need so many labeled examples so we
really want to simulate it in our way
to use the power of being active
you're also kind of assuming that it's
easy to sample from the distribution
and
that's i mean at least in the web pages
example that doesn't seem immediately
clear
so
well you can easily like you can always
uh kind of uh write them i mean the way
to um
the way you can implement this imagine
that you have a large stream of
vulnerable examples this is what you
think about you can always implement
images with velocity one labeled
examples and we're gonna go process i
mean you're gonna go through this
unlabeled examples and you'll have a
current high if you satisfy the filter
this you're gonna use those two for your
uh active estimates
so you can kind of simulate them even if
you have like a large set of unlabeled
examples at first id from the underlying
distribution you can just simulate them
um
yeah they are for all our examples yeah
they're also easy to compute yeah
obviously
okay so this is just an example uh in
our work we have uh the threshold
example obviously but in our rock we
have a number of interesting results for
more interesting concepts of spices now
let me mention just um
uh i mean
let me mention this noise tolerance
property so uh just as for passive sq
these algorithms can be easily adapted
to tolerate random classification noise
and in particular it turns out that you
can
estimate these active sq queries even if
the examples are corrupted for random
classification noise
and i'm not going to go for the details
let me just mention at the high level
the idea of the proof what we do we're
gonna uh so we're gonna break our query
into two two parts one of them will be
unaffected by noise this part over here
none of them will be affected by noise
we're gonna estimate each of them within
total and solve for two now the part of
unaffected by noise obviously we can
estimate it from noisy examples too
now the part that is affected by noise
so for this part we use the property the
the
the the our noise model we use the
random classification noise model and we
can get this nice quality over here and
so then basically if we want to estimate
this within uh
uh so this is a part two under estimated
in power two it's sufficient to estimate
uh these parts from noisy examples we
within uh one minus two times zeta times
power over two for eta is the noise
okay so this is basically the high level
idea of the proof of why you can
tolerate random classification noise and
it's really very similar to what happens
in the passive learning tool
okay and let me uh
let me now uh i'm not gonna have too
much time to go through this but let me
mention uh at the high level so our more
general result here is for learning i
think of the most interesting result
learning result is an active sq
algorithm for learning linear separators
in rd when the underlying distribution
is isotropically concave
okay and this algorithm uh
again we're going to provide an
exponential improvement in labor
complexity over passive learning
and uh let me just mention the high
level the type of algorithms that are
used it's an iterative learning
algorithm in each round they have a
current guess of the target function and
as we go along we make it closer and
closer to the target function and in
round case so what we do we run um
a passive learning algorithm on a
mixture distribution on a distribution
that is a mixture of distributions that
are so each component of the invert
mixture will be the original
distribution condition on being within a
certain band of the previous guess okay
and what we do we run a positive
algorithm on such a
such a mixed distribution to get a
separate over a really constant error
rate and
then we proceed to the next round and
the key point is that we can implement
this passive sq over this mixture
distribution by really using active skus
uh statistical queries with a field
tolerance that is never smaller than
epsilon
then uh
okay again i don't have time to go from
the details but at the high level it
turns out that if you um
if you basically pick the margins
parameters appropriate and if you
localize uh aggressively and effectively
then you can argue that only after logan
perhaps no rounds you you make the
desired progress okay and moreover in
each round uh you can show that you
don't need too many labeled examples to
uh to to make the desired progress
okay and i actually have very nice
pictures for this proof you are if you
are interested please talk to me about
it after the talk
it's very nice
i'm gonna skip all these
okay and uh um
i guess go to the
main connection to the source shop
so
a very nice bonus service framework is
that all uh all the assets that we uh
designed can be made differentially
private okay and just to be and again
this is very relevant for scenarios like
medical record analysis where data is
expensive to label
and also sensitive
okay and the specific model that we have
here is as follows so we assume that the
learner first has full access to the
unable portion of some database
okay and when the learner can request
for the labels can it cause the labels
of some of the elements of its own
choice from the database for its own
internal use
okay and then the as usual the goal of
the learner is to
output a classifier of small error
but we also want to ensure differential
privacy
and for me alpha is a privacy parameter
because epsilon is for the error rate
okay and
basically what we can show is that any
active statistical query algorithm
can be made to preserve differential
privacy
and now the number of and the point is
the number of labeled examples will only
gonna depend on on the
uh tau on the the tolerance style
parameter and the privacy parameter and
only the number of labels
only the number of unlabeled examples
are going to depend on the fused
tolerance tau f which is typically much
smaller
okay than the tolerance style
and uh
basically so uh and the proof is really
stunned that this goes into exactly by
using the laplace mechanism the exact
same way as you are in the city i'm
copying the earlier one yes
right well here i'm using okay so
the way i'm writing the theorem i'm
saying if you have an active sql query
and queries and statistical queries then
uh you can make a differential private
by using so many label requests and so
many label requests now depending on the
problem like for instance if a learning
leader separators in rb then the number
of statistical queries was going to
depend on the dimensionality
and so
and basically it's okay just a couple of
nice properties about this uh theorem is
that for instance when alpha which is
our privacy parameter is greater than
tau then we essentially get privacy for
free in terms of the number of labeled
examples in order to learn well
okay and moreover for classes for which
we have uh for which he provided active
statistical algorithms
we like so for instance for near
separator or thresholds basically it
turns out that you can learn and also
preserve differential privacy
by using much more labor requests than
even the non-private passive uh
algorithms even non-private passive
learning algorithms
and this is true as long as the privacy
parameter alpha is greater than or equal
to the final uh
desired accuracy epsilon
which i think is quite nice
all right and again i'm not going to go
for the proof the proof is really
follows
the same lines as the original proof for
the sq model of aliens in the eye and
copy
okay let me just summarize
so basically in this work
we present a framework for designing
relationship between these positive
resulting lower bounds on
sample complexity
that we have that also depend on the
bit like
representation of the data
uh
yeah so let's go into the number of
unlabeled examples right so the way i
write this theorem is like if
you always need a statistical queries of
tolerance tau and visitors then this can
when you get differential alpha
differential by receiving so many labor
requests and so many label requests now
it could easily be that the bit
complexity right i mean so the number of
such queries you need
typically the number of valuable queries
that you need will depend on the bit
complexity right if you go back even in
the very simple threshold example that i
had in my in the earlier slides right i
said if the distribution is uniform
then you only need one statistical query
saying the passive learning right but
however the distribution is not uniform
you kind of had to to use a number of
unlabeled skews actually let me go back
to this slide because i think this will
make you clarify the comment for
everyone else
this is the example right okay now out
here
right so this example over here right so
if the underlying distribution is
uniform
then you just need one sq in the usual
model you need one statistical query
right however the underlying
distribution is not uniform after you
get the answer to the first query which
is please tell me the probability of an
example is positive then you then need
to do a number of album statistical
queries to find the point z such as the
probability that the
random point belongs to the interval
zero one is very close to p
now how many level statistical queries
do you need we're gonna depend on the
bit complexity it will be basically
order of b or b is the number of bits
you need to
try down to represent your examples and
in fact we had these lower bounds which
show that it has to be the the case for
differential privacy right but but okay
but for instance going back to this
example of here again so this is for
party rescue now even in the active sq
so the point is that this bit complex
will go on the number of unlabeled
examples
so rather than the number of labeled
examples so in a word or what is
expensive is the labels like in many
medical applications what is expensive
is to maybe a test maybe the test is
invasive to see if you have a
certainties or not this is what is the
expensive part and i already have your
features i want to learn a classifier to
be able to say if you have a certain
disease or not what is expensive is for
me to run the test on you because it's
maybe invasive
right so
because i already have your features you
know your history and so on the enable
part is cheap right so i want to
minimize the number of labor requests
and so in that world you know i think
it's a very strong positive result
it's kind of cool that this bit
complexity are often okay it's not it's
not a theorem it's just in these
examples that i looked at so that
happens right
uh but for instance threshold example a
bit complexity goes into the number of
unlabeled examples it could be that for
certain problems the bitcoin place it
also goes in the number of playbook
examples like that
in these examples it's cool that that
lower bound is circumventing in terms of
the number of labeled examples
actually i have a question so uh in our
sample complexity for inner differential
privacy
learning paper what we showed is that if
you have a prior on the on where the
unlabeled data is you can and let's say
your true un-level data distribution is
a little bit different from the prior
then you could
potentially learn with differential
privacy and what you would have to pay
is logarithmic in the gap in some
distance between the prior distribution
and what your true legal distribution is
so would that translate to uh would you
know could you get these kinds of
results for statistical
learning
so again you have a prior on so let's
say you have a prior on your unlabeled
data okay but your unable data
distribution is not exactly the prior
but it's close to the prior okay and
what you could do is you could get like
sample complexity upper bounds which
depend on the gap between the price
and your uh unlabeled data distribution
okay i would expect that you could
should be able to yeah uh so but the
algorithm you know was just an uh uh
just a bound so my question is that can
you get these kinds of bounces physical
query algorithms also
so again the word is you the examples
that you get somehow are not for the
true from the trendline distribution but
from a related distribution yes
and you your goal is to do all of that
related distribution your goal is to do
well on your distribution but you have
the related distribution as a reference
to stuff so how do you use it why is it
good for you to have it uh because what
we do is we construct um essentially
what we do is we keep we first
you know we look at down level
distribution and then we uh construct
finite and final covers of that so okay
what is your improvement about the
typical uh obviously they don't have
this priority oh because you can't you
know it's it's uh you can't learn in a
distribution free way when you have
continuous data i see so just because i
see what helps you to construct the
cover and so yeah so you get finer and
finer covers at some fineness it's also
a cover for your distribution and then
you can learn
maybe just
just to illustrate it on this example if
i understand what chromoly can think the
point is like in this binary search
if your unlabeled data is um
let's say reasonably uniformly
distributed
then you don't need high precision to
find
exactly
you know a z that that gives you this
type behind z you don't need
something
right in some sense if you if everything
were in one dimension this prior
distribution tells you how to rearrange
the data so it's close to uniform and
that makes life easier
so that's i mean so most like i guess
the results would translate but i mean
there's also a question about
computational efficiency but that has to
be
i guess that has to be checked
really case by
okay it's how they expect
because in the end i mean you have this
frame or but in the end the
computational efficiency comes i mean
you have to look sit down for your
specific concept class and analyze your
favorite computational efficient
algorithm or not you don't have a magic
generic way
to design computational efficiencies
even i mean just statistical algorithms
yeah so i was curious about how this uh
you know interacts with statistical
query algorithms
so statistical queries are a special
case of
this model right so in the statistical
query you don't have the the filter
so the physical query you just ask
please tell me what's the probability
there are no examples satisfies the
property phi
and i cannot i mean i don't have the
filter function basically i cannot focus
let me actually go back again to this
slide
maybe it was too quick i spoke too
fast sometimes
right so this is i think the main
difference right so
so this generalizes the sq model right
because typically i mean with this
corresponding desk model the filter from
everything is relevant right this will
correspond the filter case everything is
relevant
right now we can the if we have this
right if you have this filter chi
now uh the point is that we can focus
right and we can use fewer labeled
examples even if we need potentially
more uh i mean
a large set of antibiotic samples and
then again i mentioned this variable
animation again so of course so we can
so this is a type of active this is an
sql query please tell me the probability
of the random example satisfies property
phi given that we satisfy the filter chi
but now of course you can simulate this
in the passive sq as well
but we need a lot more labeled examples
so really the savings comes from the
fact
that
uh
we can we can filter we can use
unlabeled examples to filter and only
you ask for labels in the relevant
portion
for we can only ask for labels of
informative examples really with respect
to the filter
type i think it has to be a filter in
the denominator
yeah
yeah yeah yeah of course
i guess any more questions
so maybe let me conclude a little bit
good so right so i present this
framework for designing uh statistical
active learning algorithms and again the
two main benefits are noise tolerance
and also
the fact that they enjoy strong
differential private
guarantees
and uh actually just as a comment maybe
at first actually when you think about
active learning and differential privacy
it's not clear that they are compatible
right because in active learning i mean
the definition original definition of
active learning you look at specific
examples right and so in different
privacy you never want to do that right
but i guess what we show is in this
framework if you design statistical
algorithms then the two can become
compatible
okay so then i think
it's nice and now sometimes of open
questions actually i think it will be
very interesting to basically so this we
saw currently only look at random
classification noise or the level of
this example is split independently of a
fixed constant probability right so be
nice to design
statistical algorithms that are also
differentially private but work in the
presence of
more adversarial noise like adversarial
level noise even malicious noise or you
can even grab the pictures so i think
that would be interesting actually i
have in the conte i have some very
exciting little results with uh where we
are able to to basically design noise
tolerant algorithms so again based on
the idea of localization we design noise
development algorithms
for adversary level noise and malicious
noise turns out to even improve over the
noise tolerance of best known passive
algorithms so these localization idea
seems to be very powerful as an
algorithmic technique
now i don't know yetif these albums are
differentially private so it would be
nice to also make them differently
private
and of course it's always nice to see
practical implications of his learning
algorithms
some more questions